les applications sur les smartphones qui
existent avec le mode satellite pour
venir vous sauver la vie lorsque vous
avez un problème qui a pas de réseau et
bien va venir se connecter au satellite
on l'a vu notamment avec les iPhone et
puis ça se voit de plus en plus et même
sur Android et là il y a une solution
qui est super intéressante avec une
petite puce de médiathèque à l'intérieur
qui permet de venir connecter alors là
c'est Brandt Motorola mais vous allez
pouvoir venir le connecter à n'importe
quel appareil iOS Android en Bluetooth
directement vous avez un petit bouton
SOS parce que vous avez un problème
c'est l'avenir vous connecter
directement au satellite et venir vous
repérer directement pour venir vous
sauver je trouve ça super intéressant
parce que cette question vous n'avez pas
de réseau Vous avez besoin de secours et
bien ça se développe de plus en plus
pour la fin nécessairement un smartphone
avec une offre satellite on n'a pas
forcément besoin de le changer on n'a
pas forcément toujours les moyens et
bien on peut venir acquérir ce petit
objet qui peut venir vous sauver la vie
je trouve ça extrêmement intelligent
extrêmement malin d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous êtes déjà retrouvé dans une
situation vous aviez besoin de pouvoir
appeler les secours sans capter sans
avoir du réseau à quel moment dans les
commentaires et une fois de plus ce
petit objet pourrait réellement venir
vous sauver